I haven't been home in a long time and
I'm actually home and we're gonna we're
all here we're out here in the wild the
wilderness we are it's windy hi Phil did
you put sunscreen sunscreen no I'm
trying to get a tan it's great yeah what
you think so far
um well a lot better horizon than I
expected oh wait till you see the actual
horizon a lot of mountains are there
scorpions in California is that the
thing there's rattlesnakes really what
so one guy use it they were like him and
his wife drivers I'm just hanging out of
snakes rattlesnakes it was true yeah no
I don't I don't let's turn back no yeah
I'm doubting that that's good let's go
get some dinner or something I'm down
dog for some like food
maybe cupcakes mmm blueberry Froyo so
I'm done Froyo you got that on the
calendar that's like that's not for a
while we still how you're right there's
a lot of things on a calendar just even
fill them up no it's already filled up a
lot of days filled up perfect
[Music]
nice views ah
wait so you did lose your phone okay
this is not good partway through the
hike actually not even a half mile in
that realized guess what he doesn't have
phone phone squad goals my sex super
helicopter together what I'll request a
great idea
hey did you know there's a shortcut
whenever you're playing GTA if we hit Y
and you're the helicopter yeah you fall
out of a plane right yep you got a big
gaping gap I dropped my phone on this
rock right there it's now my phone is
safely in my pocket
clerk a lot made fun of your pocket like
I'm I have chapstick you don't know
what's kind of ironic about all this is
Jenna asked me if I wanted her to put
anything in her pockets and I said no
true and now he's probably gonna cost me
my phone it's very true it's gonna cost
me like listen listen a very wide nose
listen to your elders so we just
finished playing some Mario Kart we've
hit a lot of Mario Kart I just want to
show you this ridiculous setup that we
have here it was a hot mess
we had camera here sitting on top of my
Ricki Lake book a good microphone and
when we sat here and played all
connected to my laptop but it's
connected through this USB hub connected
to the elgato el gato
l got to L got to over there a lot of
themed decorations I like to really I
really love interior decorating
[Music]
a lot of things happening still I'm just
gonna be okay hope I don't see you later
bye
[Music]